dernière grande répétition générale pour
le spectacle secret défense produit par
polaris et les monuments nationaux il
retrace la rencontre entre les
présidents eisenhower et de gaulle en
pleine guerre froide à quelques semaines
de la représentation celle au moment de
régler les derniers détails comme détail
aujourd'hui typiquement il ya une scène
dans le spectacle où deux groupes qui
ont été divisées au début du spectacle
doivent se retrouver et si elle ne se
retrouve pas au bon moment et bien ça
décale tout ce spectacle et c'est
compliqué puisqu'il des admissions
public toutes les dix minutes
aujourd'hui on voit surtout des détails
de coiffure de costumes et des petits
détails de mise en scène qui va aller à
mener l'accessoire d'un figurant un
autre pour que la scène fonctionne bien
qui va ouvrir les portes qui va
déclencher les bandes sont toutes ces
derniers calages de dernière minute
qu'on a besoin de faire forcément après
la première qui dans trois semaines
maintenant un spectacle qui demande
beaucoup d'organisation et de précision
puisque au total ces 600 volontaires qui
deviennent des acteurs des figurants des
choristes ou encore des petites mains en
coulisses je suis un acteur dans la
scène du cabinet je joue thomas gets
junior le secrétaire d'état à la défense
américaine je suis chef d'atelier avec
mes trois coéquipiers donc
marie-christine isabelle et puis renault
sur la chambre des délégations coiffure
décor placement tout est vu et revu pour
que ça soit parfait le jour j après deux
ans de préparation tout le monde est
impatient dans l'ensemble on est quand
même assez près les derniers détails se
met au fur à mesure effectivement
en jouant en jouant mais là on est on
est suffisamment près pour partir plutôt
sereine parce que je suis totalement
confiante déjà dans l'équipe polaris qui
nous accompagnent qui nous donne une
force mais extraordinaire on est sûr ça
va être une belle expérience immersive
pour tous les âges et pour tout les
appétences c'est à dire qu'on et une
connaissance très précise de l'histoire
que cela soit pas particulièrement une
période qui nous intéresse c'est
vraiment un spectacle qui s'adresse à
tous et à toutes le spectacle secret
défense se déroulera du 10 juin au 3
juillet au château de rambouillet tous
les vendredis soirs où les samedis et
les dimanches de 9h à 23h les
spectateurs seront immergés en 1959
durant une heure
[Musique]